Alright guys, so this is going to be the lecture for chapter 18 part A on the cardiovascular
system.
Be sure to look out for part B. It should be published usually within three to four days
after the first part will be published.
If it's not ready, just hang in there.
Sometimes I get real busy, so I appreciate your patience.
So let's get started now.
So this first slide here says why this matters, how the anatomy and physiology of the heart
affect the sounds hurt through a stethoscope.
So think about when you go to your doctor and they're listening to your chest.
They're usually listening for two things.
First of all, at the chest level, they're listening to your lungs and heart.
So if they're not listening to your lungs, then they're listening to your heart.
And when they listen to your heart, they can hear the beat, alright, and you can also feel
the beat of the heart by pulse.
But you can listen to that as well.
In addition to that, you can also hear the blood flowing through the heart, specifically
one of the things that they'll be listening for is blood moving through the valves.
And sometimes if there's anomalies with that, that can be heard through the stethoscope.
As they progress through this lecture, hopefully you'll get a better understanding of this
and this will make much more sense to you.
And if you guys have a lab section tied into your anatomy physiology course, perhaps there
might be a stethoscope available.
You can ask your instructor and you may be able to listen to your own hearts or that of
your lab partners.
So this next slide here is the video why this matters.
Be sure to look at it if your book came with a DVD or you can just go to the Pearson website
and access this.
So moving on to this slide, the hearts anatomy, which you're going to be looking at, the very
first thing you want to look at is the word cardiovascular.
So let's just go back to the very first slide.
Cardiovascular.
What do we have?
Heart and we have blood vessels, okay?
So cardiovascular is blood vessels.
Now, the heart and blood vessels, also within the heart and blood vessels, what do we find?
We find blood flowing through it.
So we have three things, blood which looked in the last chapter and now we're looking
at the heart in this chapter and the next chapter, we're going to be looking at the
blood vessels.
So there's three things that this cardiovascular system is made up of.
And as I told you in the previous lecture, think about the cardiovascular system as a
transportation system that's going to be sending things throughout your body.
Think of the blood vessels as a route, the delivery routes that goes to all the tissues
of your body.
Think of blood as the carriers or the medium which substances are going to be transported
through and think about the heart as the pump, the energy source that's going to be pushing
all that blood through that's going to be powering this transportation system.
So we have this cardiovascular system, again, remember three things that it consists of,
blood, blood vessels and heart.
In this chapter here, we're specifically looking at the heart.
So remember, the heart, as I mentioned earlier, this is the energy source for the cardiovascular
system.
What is it doing?
It's pumping blood throughout the body.
So the heart is actually a pump, but it's made up of two side by side pumps.
The right side of the heart receives oxygen for blood from tissues that's found throughout
our body.
So what happens up happening when blood is, first oxygen to blood is sent to the tissues,
what happens?
The tissues get that oxygen.
When the tissue gets that oxygen, it uses it, but then it produces waste.
And one of the waste products that produces carbon dioxide, now that carbon dioxide needs
to be taken away from the tissue.
So what ends up happening is when the blood is passing back, it's coming back to the heart.
It's going to bring back that deoxygenated blood along with the carbon dioxide.
Now once the blood is in the right side of the heart, the right side of the heart is
going to pump it to the lungs.
When blood leaves the right side of the heart and goes to the lungs, it's part of the pulmonary
circuit.
Now once that blood is in the lungs, it's going to get rid of the carbon dioxide.
When we breathe out, carbon dioxide goes, when we breathe in, what do we do?
We're breathing in air, we're breathing in oxygen.
So now your blood ends up getting that oxygen back into it.
So now that oxygen rich blood is going to come back to the left side of the heart.
When it comes to the left side of the heart, it will then get pumped out to the rest of
the body.
And once that happens, that's said to be the blood is said to be in the systemic circuit.
So when blood leaves the left side of the heart, it's in systemic circuit.
The heart has two receiving chambers, the right atrium and the left atrium.
The right atrium receives blood from the systemic circuit and the left atrium receives blood
from the pulmonary circuit.
In other words, the right atrium is getting blood back from all over our body and the
left atrium is getting blood back from the lungs.
Get rid of the pulmonary, lungs, systemic, your entire system.
The pumping chambers of the heart are the right ventricle and the left ventricle.
The right ventricle is always pumping blood to the lungs.
So it's going to be pumping blood to the pulmonary circuit and the left ventricle is
going to be pumping blood to the rest of your body.
So it's going to be pumping blood to the systemic circuit.
This slide goes over the systemic and the pulmonary circuits.
So when you look at this legend over here, the red represents the oxygen rich blood,
which is also known as oxygenated blood.
And oxygenated blood is also going to be pouring carbon dioxide.
The blue represents the oxygenated blood or oxygen poor blood, which is also going to
be rich in carbon dioxide.
Now this area over here represents a capillary and remember, is that the capillaries that
we have the exchange of gases and nutrients taking place?
So let's imagine that this is a capillary of this arm muscle over here, one of the muscles
of the arm.
So what do we have over here?
Remember the red represents oxygenated blood.
So we have oxygenated blood that's coming over here.
Oxygen is going to leave here and then it's going to end up going to this muscle cells.
Muscle cells are going to use oxygen and they produce carbon dioxide.
Now that carbon dioxide enters back on this blue part, which is the veins over here.
Of course, this is an artery, this is a vein.
So it's going to end up coming back by these veins back to this heart over here.
And which side of the heart does it come back to?
The right side, okay?
And remember, when you look over here, this is going to be the right and well, let me
get this pen out.
So this is always the right side, remember anatomical position.
And this is going to be the left side, right?
So, all right, it's written over here already, right and left.
So yes, the blood is going to come back to the right side of the heart.
So this is this right atrium.
Now this deoxygenated blood, when it comes back to the right atrium, it's then going
to go to the right ventricle.
When the right ventricle contracts, it's going to be pumping blood to the lungs.
Now when the blood leaves this right ventricle and it enters its blood vessel, now it's
part of the pulmonary circuit, okay?
So this is the pulmonary artery, remember arteries, they always pump blood away from
the heart.
Arrays always pump blood away from the heart.
Veins always bring blood back to the heart, okay?
Veins always bring blood back to the heart.
Don't forget this.
Arrays always pumping blood away from the heart.
Veins always bring blood back to the heart.
So when the blood gets pumped from this right ventricle and it enters this right pulmonary
artery, at that point we say that it's in pulmonary circuits, and the pulmonary circuit
blood is in the pulmonary circuit.
So by the pulmonary arteries, this deoxygenated blood which is also rich in carbon dioxide
will be sent to the lungs.
Now remember, when we breathe out, we breathe out carbon dioxide, and when we breathe in,
we breathe in oxygen.
So the oxygen will end up coming back into the lungs when you breathe in, and then this
blood will get oxygenated.
So when the blood gets oxygenated, then it ends up coming back to the heart by the pulmonary
veins to the left atrium.
Then from the left atrium, the blood is going to go down over here to this left ventricle.
Then from here, the blood is going to go into this aorta, okay?
This is the largest artery we have in our body.
So once the blood comes into the aorta, at that point we say that it's in systemic circuit.
So remember, pulmonary circuit, when the blood leaves the right ventricle, it's in the pulmonary
circuit, and when the blood leaves the left ventricle, it's in the systemic circuit or
systemic circulation.
As for the size, location, and orientation of the heart, the heart is roughly the size
of a fist.
It weighs anywhere from 250 to 350 grams, which is under a pound.
In a pound, there's about 450 some grams.
For the location, the heart is located in the media stynum between the second rib and
the fifth intracostal space.
The heart is found sitting on top of the diaphragm, which is the main breathing muscle
of our body.
So in addition to the diaphragm, there's other structures that the heart is anchored
onto.
Two-thirds of the heart is more on the left side, so it's said to be left of the midsternal
line.
So remember, in the middle of the sternum, this is the imaginary line.
So it's to the left of this imaginary line or the midsternal line.
Because the heart is slightly more to the left side of the body than the right, our
left lung is a little bit more smaller than the right lung.
The left lung has two lobes, while the right lung has three lobes.
We find the heart anterior to the vertebral column and posterior to the sternum.
So it's found behind the ribs and in front of the backbones.
So this slide is a nice illustration that goes over the location of the heart.
So the first thing that you want to see right over here is our breastbone or our sternum.
So over here you can see the manubrium.
The body is going to be over here and then right over here we have the zyphoid process.
So if you draw an imaginary line right in the middle of this sternum, this is called the
midsternal line, midsternal line.
Now remember, this is the right side and here we have the left side.
So notice the heart is a little bit more to the left side.
It's more to this midsternal line, it's more left to this midsternal line.
And because of that, this lung that's going to be found over here is going to be a little
bit smaller, while the lung over here is going to be found over here is going to be a little
bit more larger.
The other thing is, when you count the ribs, here's the first rib, here's your second
rib.
So you can see that from the second rib going all the way down to the third, fourth, fifth
and this is the fifth intercostal space is where the heart is going to be found.
So you can see that the heart is found behind the sternum and in front of the back bone over
here, or your vertebral column.
The other thing that I wanted to mention is that right over here, this pointy part, this
is called the apex of the heart.
While this upper part over here, the broad part of the heart is called the base of the
heart.
So this is the base and this is the apex.
This slide here, we're looking at a cross section of the thoracic cavity.
So you can see the heart is found over here and laterally on both sides, we have the lungs
that are found.
So when you look over here, this region right over here, this is the media stinum, this
area right over here, between the lungs.
Now we find the heart anterior to this bone over here, which are the thoracic vertebrae.
And then we find the heart posterior to this bone over here, which is going to be your sternum
or your breast bone.
The posterior surface of the heart is known as the base and it measures roughly three and
a half inches in length and it leans towards the right shoulder.
This sharp pointy part of the heart is called the apex and it points towards the left hip.
Now when this apex on the heart contracts, the apex, it makes contact with the chest
wall.
So if you were to take two fingers and you place it between the fifth and six ribs below
your left nipple, you would be able to feel that and that's called the apical impulse.
So again, apical impulse is nothing more than the apex making contact with the chest wall.
So we looked at this slide earlier.
So again, we have a heart over here.
So this part up over here, this is the base.
This is the apex.
This is the sharp pointy part.
So notice this is pointing towards the left hip and this points towards your right shoulder.
So this part over here, when the heart contracts, when this apex, when it touches the chest
wall, you should be able to feel it and this is called the apical impulse.
So remember, this is between the fifth and six ribs.
So right over here, this is where your nipple would be, your left nipple.
So right about over here, this is where you should be able to feel it in this area.
So in this slide over here, we looked at this earlier as well.
So what do we have here?
This is our heart.
So remember, the heart is found within this area here, which is the media stinum.
And then when you look over here, we have our vertebrae and then we have our sternum over
here.
So remember, the heart is found posterior to the sternum and it's found anterior to the
vertebrae.
And we have the heart being flanked on the right and left lateral aspects by the lungs.
So right over here, you can find this base over here.
So this is what they refer to as the base of the heart.
Moving on to the coverings of the heart, we have the pericardium, which is a doubled
walled sack that surrounds the heart and it's made up of two layers.
It's made up of a superficial fibrous pericardium and it's made up of a serous pericardium.
Now, the fibrous pericardium, its main job is to protect, also anchor the heart in place
to the surrounding structures such as the diaphragm, the sternum, in addition to some
of the blood vessels that we have there.
And it also prevents the heart from overfilling with blood.
As to the serous pericardium, it actually consists of two layers.
It's made up of a parietal layer and a visceral layer.
The parietal layer, it lines the internal surface of the fibrous pericardium.
And the visceral layer, which is also known as the epicardium, is found on the external
surface of the heart.
Now these two layers, the visceral and the parietal layers, are separated by a fluid-filled
cavity called a pericardial cavity.
The pericardial cavity contains serous fluid, which decreases the friction between the two
layers as the heart contracts.
So this slide goes over the layers of the pericardium and the heart wall.
And this is an important slide to understand because the next few slides that we go over
is going to be in reference to what we look at over here, in addition to what we spoke
about in the last slide.
So what we're looking at over here is a part of the heart.
And this is probably an atria that we're looking at.
So it's part of this upper chamber of the heart.
So when you look over here, what you're going to see is right over here, this is the inside
of the chamber.
So this is going to be the inside of the atria.
And when you look at it over here, the roof of this atria, we find this has this endocardium.
So this is one of the walls of the heart, which is the endocardium.
Now the second part of the heart is this or the second part of the wall of the heart
is the myocardium.
So endocardium, myocardium, and finally we have the epicardium.
So these are the three layers of the heart, epicardium, myocardium, and the endocardium.
Okay, so remember after the endocardium what we have, the inside of the chambers of the
heart.
Okay, so this is the atria, could have very well been in ventricle.
But what you're going to find out at ventricles, you're going to find a lot more muscle over
there, not thin muscle like this.
So anyways, that's something else we'll be looking at.
But well here, you can see it over here as well.
So notice at the ventricle you have a lot more muscle, whereas the atria have very little
muscle over here, same thing on this side, very little muscle where you have a lot more
muscle found at the ventricles.
Now coming back over here, so remember what we're looking at, this is the endocardium.
Okay, then we have the myocardium, finally we have the epicardium.
Now when we talk about the fibrous pericardium and the serous pericardium, now let's look
at these structures.
We'll talk about that in the last slide.
So the fibrous pericardium, remember, this is made of this dense connective tissue, and
this is the outer part of that sac that we're going to find.
So here it is right over here, this is fibrous pericardium over there and over here.
Now after you the fibrous pericardium, we find this, the parietal layer of the serous
pericardium, and this is this part over here.
So as you see what happens is, this parietal layer, you find it right underneath this fibrous
pericardium, and this parietal layer of this serous pericardium, it's going to go and it
turns over, it flips over.
When it flips over and then it comes into making contact with this myocardium, okay, then this
is what we refer to as this visceral layer of the serous membrane or epicardium, it's
the same thing.
The visceral layer of the serous membrane is also called the epicardium, which is also
the outermost wall of the heart, okay.
So and you will see that in the slide that we go over.
So remember, how does this happen?
It happens by this parietal layer of the serous pericardium, so this parietal layer, it comes
over and it flips over.
When it flips over, it turns into this visceral layer of the serous membrane, okay.
When this parietal layer flips over, it becomes the epicardium.
Now what will what happens is, if you notice, you have this space over here.
So when this parietal layer, when it flips over, it forms this cavity right over the space,
and this is this paracardial cavity and it's over here, within this cavity, we have serous
fluid that's found.
So as the heart beats, what happens is, these two layers, they slip past one another, so
you get no friction, okay.
So sometimes you can have some conditions we're going to be talking about in the next
few slides.
When this two layers and they start rubbing up too much, it you end up getting inflammation.
And then in certain cases, what could happen is that you could end up having fluid that
starts to accumulate.
If you start getting fluid accumulating, now what ends up happening is that this heart
cannot contract anymore because that fluid is starting to push down on this muscle.
So if you think about it, if you got fluid pushing down on this muscle, it's going to
be very difficult for it to contract.
And that's a very, you know, it's a big problem.
So we'll look at that in the next slide.
But again, make sure you understand this.
What do we have here?
Remember, this is this the epicardium, which is a visceral layer of the serous membrane.
Then you have the myocardium, then you have the endocardium, then finally we have the
heart chamber.
Back over here, remember, do not forget these structures.
These are very good exam questions that are very likely to be on our dietids, it's just
inflammation of the pericardium, which roughens the surface of the serous membrane.
And as the heart beats and rubs against the pericardial sac, it makes a creaking sound,
which is called a pericardial friction rub, that we can hear with the stethoscope.
In severe cases, large amounts of inflammatory fluid seep into the pericardial cavity.
The axis fluid then starts pushing down on the heart, limiting its ability to contract
and pump blood.
This is called cardiac tympanate, and the way you treat this condition is with needle
and syringe.
A doctor will insert the needle into the pericardial cavity, and aspirate that axis fluid with
the syringe.
Now let's take a look at the layers of the heart.
As we mentioned earlier, there's three layers of the heart wall, the epicardium, the myocardium,
and the endocardium.
So let's start off with the outermost layer, which is the epicardium.
So as we mentioned earlier, this is also the visceral layer of the serous pericardium.
The epicardium also contains a lot of fat, which you mostly see in older people.
The middle layer is the myocardium.
This is a muscle layer of the heart, which forms the bulk of the heart.
The muscle cells are arranged in circular spiral bundles, and tethered to one another,
by crisscrossing connective tissue fibers.
These connective tissue fibers also form a dense network called the fibrous skeleton
of the heart, which reinforces the myocardium internally, and anchors the cardiac muscle
fibers.
It also provides additional support to where the great vessels emerge at the heart and
are on the valves of the heart.
And this is quite important, because these structures are under constant pressure from
the blood moving through them.
So if they didn't have this, these structures could eventually become stretched.
And lastly, one of the attributes of connective tissue is that it's not electrically excitable.
And because of this property, the fiber skeleton limits the direct spread of action potentials
across the heart to specific pathways.
And in this slide here, we're looking at the muscle bundles that we find in the heart.
So when you look over here, these are the circular bundles.
So this is the atria.
This is where we would find the atria.
So what's happening over here in the atria is that you want to push the blood from this
chamber down to this next chamber.
So these muscle fibers, they're oriented in a circular fashion, so that when it squeezes,
the content, which is the blood, will get forced down into this direction.
Now when you look over here, these muscle fibers now, they're oriented more in a spiral fashion,
because this is a ventricle now.
This is your right ventricle.
So what's going to happen over here is we want the blood to go into this next blood vessel.
And this blood vessel that is going to be going to is found somewhere over here.
So it's not going to be much use if the force that's going to be squeezing that blood out
is going to be going downwards as it was over here.
So instead, we have it at an angle, because the blood vessels over here, we want the force
to go this way.
And this is why these muscles are arranged in this fashion over here.
And on this side over here, so for the left ventricle, it's the same as the right ventricle.
The force needs to be going downwards.
Now over here, notice that the direction is opposite to this, it's a mirror image, because
what we want over here is the next blood vessel is going to be somewhere right over here.
So when this contracts, the blood needs to be pushed up this way, which is why we have
these fibers arranged in this fashion here, in this spiral fashion.
Lastly, we come to the third and innermost layer of the heart, which is the endocardium.
The endocardium consists of a sheet of endothelium that lies on top of a thin layer of connective
tissue.
The endocardium is continuous with the endothelial lining of the blood vessels, which enter and
leave the heart.
It also lines all the chambers of the heart and covers the fiber skeleton of the valves.
Coming back to this slide, what we want to look at are the three layers.
So right over here, this is the epicardium, which is also the visceral layer of the serous
pericardium.
Then we have this middle layer, which is the myocardium.
Then finally, we have the endocardium.
Now let's look at the internal features of the heart.
As we mentioned earlier, the heart has four chambers.
Two chambers on top are called the atria, and the two chambers on the bottom are called
the ventricles.
Now between the two chambers, there is a wall that walls called the septum.
So when we're looking at the wall that's found between the two atria, that's called
the inter-atrial septum.
When we're looking at the wall that's found between the ventricles, it's called the inter-ventricular
septum.
If you break down the word, it's so much easier to remember and memorize.
So look at this word, inter means between atrial, it refers to the atria.
Septum means wall, so inter-atrial septum.
In this case over here, ventricular refers to the ventricles.
Inter once again is between, and septum is a wall.
So the wall that's found between the ventricles, inter-atrial septum, inter-ventricular septum.
Going back to the ventricles in atria, the right ventricle forms most of the anterior
surface of the heart, while the left ventricle forms the heart's apex and most of the inferior
posterior aspects of the heart.
And when we look at the inter-atrial septum, we find a shallow depression that's called
the fossa ovelus, which was an opening called the foramen ovale in the fetal heart.
Moving on to the side over here, this is a cross section that's revealing some of the
internal structures of the heart.
So the first thing that we want to look at is this chamber up over here.
This is our right atrium.
Going to the left side, we have the left atrium.
When you go below the left atrium, you have the left ventricle.
And on the opposite side, when you go below the right atrium, we find the right ventricle.
Between the right and left ventricle, we have this wall over here.
This is the inter-ventricular septum.
Now we can't see the wall between the right and left atria because of this blood vessel
that we have over here.
But again, it would be found between these two walls of the atria.
The next thing we want to look at is this depression here, which is called the fossa
ovelus.
And remember, in the fetus, this is called the foramen ovale.
It was in small opening.
Now this is the tricuspid valve, and we'll be talking about this.
But again, this valve, if you look over here, there's three cusps.
So it's called the tricuspid, whereas over here, there's only two cusps.
So this is called the bicuspid valve, also known as the mitral valve.
Again, we'll come back to looking at this.
The next we want to look at is right over here.
These are the pectinated muscles.
So notice we find this on the anterior wall of the right atrium, and when you go to the
left atrium, we don't see it present, because in the left atrium, we're going to find them
in the oracles.
And let's stop over here for this slide, and we'll come back to it as we learn a little
bit more structures.
Moving on to the surface features of the heart.
There are two visible grooves found on the surface of the heart that indicate the boundaries
of the four chambers, in addition to carrying the blood vessels supplying the myocardium.
They are the coronary sulcus and the anterior and posterior interventricular sulky.
The coronary sulcus, which is also known as the atrial ventricular groove, encircles
a junction of the atrium ventricles like a crown.
The anterior interventricular sulcus is found creating the anterior interventricular artery,
in addition to marking the anterior position of the septum, separating the right and left
ventricles.
It continues as a posterior interventricular sulcus, providing a similar landmark on the
posterior surface of the heart.
Moving on to this slide, we're looking at the anterior view of the heart, so we're looking
at the surface structures of the heart.
The first thing that we notice are this and this, these two structures here, these are
called the oracles of the atria.
Oracle means ear.
Whoever first saw this structure, it looked like an ear to them and they got to name
it.
You find it, you get to name whatever you want.
This is the right oracle of the right atria and this is the left oracle of the left atrium.
Coming down over here, we want to see this area here.
This is your right ventricle.
So is that the right ventricle forms most of the anterior aspect of the heart and when
you come down over here, this is the apex of the heart.
Now the apex is formed by the left ventricle and when you go to the posterior view, when
you look at the posterior view of the heart, we're going to see that the left ventricle
forms most of the posterior aspect of the heart.
Now coming over here, first of all, this is a pulmonary trunk and we're going to be talking
about this.
When this chamber contracts this right ventricle, blood rushes into this blood vessel here, this
pulmonary trunk, which then divides into a right and left side and I'm not going to
get into that but we'll be talking about that.
And right over here, this is called the superior vena cava, this is the inferior vena cava.
Blood returns back to the heart into the right atrium by these two blood vessels.
But let's look at what we spoke about in the last slide, which is the coronary sulcus.
Now this coronary sulcus, this is this groove in which this artery lies within and this is
the right coronary artery.
The other thing that we spoke about was the interventricular sulcus, okay, the anterior
and posterior interventricular sulcus.
So since we're looking at the anterior aspect of the heart, we're going to be looking at
the anterior interventricular sulcus.
So when you look over here, this blood vessel is lying within this anterior interventricular
sulcus.
So now we're looking at a posterior view of the heart.
So this is a posterior surface of the heart and notice this is mostly the left ventricle
that makes up this posterior surface of the heart.
So right over here, we can see the left atrium and these are the pulmonary veins.
This is the left pulmonary vein, this is the right pulmonary vein.
Again, I'm not going to talk too much about this because when we take a look at it, when
we talk more about this as we move along in the lecture, the other thing that you want
to look at is right over here, this is this posterior interventricular sulcus that we're
looking at here, the posterior interventricular sulcus.
So again, it's a little bit difficult to see, but these blood vessels are actually the residing
within this groove, this posterior interventricular sulcus.
Moving on to the atrium, these are the receiving chambers of the heart.
The receiving blood from the lungs and the receiving blood from the rest of our body.
So when you look at these chambers, they're relatively small compared to the ventricles.
They're also much thinner walled.
There's not too much muscle that's present there.
The main reason is because gravity is doing most of the work.
Remember, blood goes from the atria down to the ventricles.
So gravity is pushing that blood down into the ventricles, the atrial do not need too
much muscle there.
The muscle that is there, it's there mainly to make sure that the blood that's found within
that chamber empties and it empties in a timely manner.
In other words, we want it to empty rather quickly, not too late because as we learn,
as we move through the chapters, the heart beats in a specific pattern and that beating
all correlates to transferring blood from chamber to chamber.
So keep that in mind.
The walls of the atria are thin, and they're thin because we don't need too much muscles
there.
Gravity does most of the work.
Now oracles we saw on the surface of the heart, if you think back, remember, they kind
of look like ears.
All this does is that it increases the surface area to hold blood for the atria.
So again, it's increasing the atrial volume.
When you look at the right atrium, it's receiving deoxygenated blood from our body, from the
systemic circulation.
And when you look at the inner surface of the atrium, the posterior portion is smooth
walled.
When you move towards the anterior portion of the atrium, we're going to find these ridges
that are formed by these muscle groups called pectinate muscles.
And when you look at this word pectin, it means comb.
When you look at these muscle bundles, they kind of look like the tooth of a comb, and
that's how they're named, the pectinate muscles.
When you go to the left atrium, we're not going to find the pectinate muscles on the
anterior portion.
They're going to be found on the oracles instead.
And the posterior and anterior regions of the right atrium are separated by a C-shaped
ridge called the Christa Tremenalis.
There are three veins that empty into the right atrium.
Those are the superior vena cava, the inferior vena cava, and the coronary sinus.
All the blood that's above the diaphragm ends up returning back to the heart by the
superior vena cava.
All the blood that's below the diaphragm will return back to the heart by the inferior
vena cava.
And the coronary sinus will drain all the blood that's circulating within the coronary veins
back to the heart.
In other words, all the blood that's being supplied to the heart to work gets returned
back by the coronary sinus.
All the blood that's going to your head, your arms, your chest, that returns back from
the superior vena cava.
And when you're looking at your digestive organs, your kidneys, your legs, all that
blood gets returned back to the heart by the inferior vena cava.
As for the left atrium, it receives oxygenated blood back from the lungs by four pulmonary
veins.
And as I mentioned earlier, we only find the pecinated muscles in the oracles of the left
atrium.
In this slide here, we looked at this image earlier, but let's go over it again along
with the new information that we learned.
So, we'll start off with this right atrium here, and we said the right atrium receives
blood from three blood vessels, which are the superior vena cava, the inferior vena
cava, and the coronary sinus, which you don't see here because it's found on the posterior
surface of the heart.
The superior vena cava, it's returning blood back to this chamber from regions above the
diaphragm.
So, think about our face, our head, our brain, our arms, our fingers.
All that blood is coming back by this superior vena cava.
The inferior vena cava, on the other hand, is returning blood back from regions below
the diaphragm.
So, think about our toes, our feet, our legs, our intestines, our stomach, kidney, liver.
All that blood is coming back by the inferior vena cava.
The coronary sinus, it's going to be returning blood that's in coronary circulation.
So, all the blood that's supplying all these muscle cells here, the heart muscle cells,
with oxygen and nutrients, returns back by the coronary sinus, and empties that blood
into this right atrium.
Now, when you look at the walls over here, the anterior wall of the right atrium, we
find these pectinate muscles that are present, then we go to the left atrium, these pectinate
muscles are not present.
On the left atrium, the pectinate muscles will be found on the oracles of the left atrium.
The last thing that I wanted to mention are the four blood vessels that are returning
oxygenated blood back from the lungs to this left atrium.
Those are the right and left pulmonary veins.
Moving on to the ventricles, both the right and left ventricles make up most of the volume
of the heart.
These are the main pumping chambers.
As you looked at earlier pictures, the right ventricle forms most of the heart's anterior
surface, while the left ventricle forms most of the posterior inferior surface, in addition
to forming the heart's apex.
When you look at the internal walls of the chambers, we find these irregular ridges of
muscle called the trabeculae carnier.
There are also these cone-shaped muscles that project into the cavity called the papillary
muscles.
The papillary muscles play a role in the function of the heart valves.
They're connected to the quarteteninae, which in turn are connected to the atrial ventricular
valves.
Compared to the atria, the ventricles have much thicker walls.
Remember, these chambers are the main pumping chambers of the heart.
The right ventricle is going to be pumping blood to the lungs by way of the pulmonary
trunk, while the left ventricle is going to be pumping blood to the rest of the body,
including the heart, by way of the largest artery we have in our body called the aorta.
Returning back to this picture, we'll now look at the ventricles.
So this is the right ventricle, and this is the left ventricle.
Now when we look at this right and left ventricles, the first thing that I see that catches my
attention are these muscles here and here, which are sticking into this chamber.
These are the papillary muscles.
The papillary muscles are connected to these rope-like structures called the quarteteninae.
The quarteteninae, then you connect it to these valves over here and over here.
These are the atrial ventricular valves.
The other thing that you should notice is how much stronger the muscular walls are in the
ventricles compared to in the atria.
Now remember, when the atria contract, what are they doing?
They're sending blood from this chamber just down over here, and most of it, the gravity
is doing the work.
When these valves open up, what happens to the blood that's sitting over here?
It's going to fall in.
The ventricles when they contract, they're helping to squeeze that blood out quickly.
That's their main job, so they don't need too much muscle to do that.
Now, in the case of the ventricles, when this right ventricle contracts, it needs to send
blood to the lungs.
So in order to do that, it needs muscle, but you know what?
It doesn't need that much muscle because the heart is very close to the lungs.
Compared to the left ventricle, notice how much more muscle that we find over here.
When this chamber contracts, it needs to be able to send blood against gravity into our
brain.
It needs to be able to send blood to our extremities, such as our fingers and toenails.
These are very far away.
So the muscle needs to be strong, there needs to be a lot more muscle here, to create that
pressure, to be able to push it out of this chamber and send it to all those distant places.
Lastly, I wanted to point out these muscles over here and over here.
These are called the trabeculae carnier, okay?
The trabeculae carnier.
In this slide here, we have a photograph of the heart, so this is the apex of the heart.
Moving superiorly, this is the left ventricle.
And here's the myocardium of the left ventricle.
This here is the largest artery of the body, which is the aorta.
Since this part is going upwards, it's referred to as the ascending aorta.
Next, we'll define the superior vena cava.
And this over here are the pectinate muscles that we have in the right atrium.
When you go down over here, this is the C-shaped ridge, the chrystal terminalis, and then we
can also see the inter-atrial septum here.
So remember, this is the wall that separates the right and left atrium.
Going down here, this is that fossa ovales.
And inferior to that, we find the opening of the coronary sinus.
Next to that, we have the opening of the inferior vena cava, which has been cut.
And then over here, you can see the inter-ventricular sulcus right over here.
On this slide here, we have an anterior view of the heart with some of the structures dissected.
So when you look over here, this is the inter-ventricular septum.
This is the wall that divides the right and left ventricles.
Now notice over here, this is a myocardium with the left ventricle.
Notice how much thicker this is compared to that of the right ventricle.
The right ventricle, remember when it contracts, it's sending blood to the lungs.
So what do you find in the lungs?
The lungs are found to the right and left of the heart.
The heart is sandwiched between the right and left lungs.
Therefore, it doesn't need to go too far.
We don't need too much muscle over here.
Compared to this side over here, this side where it contracts, it's sending blood all
the way down to our toes, to our feet.
It needs to go against gravity to go all the way to our brain.
Therefore, we need to generate a lot more pressure.
I'm going to get that by having a lot more muscle.
And this is why we have a much thicker myocardium on the left side.
Now looking into this chamber, these structures over here, these are the trabeculae carnier.
And then when you look over here, this is a papillary muscle.
These papillary muscles, if you notice, here's another one over here, they project inwards
into this chamber.
Now they in return connect to these quartetenia.
The quartetenia in return connect to this.
We can't see it over here, but you can see it over here.
This is a atroventricular valve.
The atroventricular valve that we find on this right side over here and the right ventricle
is called the tricuspid valve.
And on the left side over here, it's called the mitral valve or bicuspid valve.
Now moving along, this over here, this is a pulmonary trunk.
So when this chamber contracts, blood ends up coming up over here.
Now this is a aorta and this is the largest artery we have in our body.
And you can see some of the branches that are coming off of this aorta over here.
So this is going to be the left subclavian artery.
Over here, we have the left common choroid artery.
And this is a brachiocephalic trunk.
This here right here is a superior vinecava.
And over here, you can see the oracles of the right atrium and the oracle of the left
atrium.
Here's the opening for the pulmonary vane.
Over here, it's been cut.
And I think that's about it.
I think we hit just about all the things that we should be looking at over here.
On this side here, we have an animation of the heart.
So be sure to go to the Pearson website.
You can search for it on YouTube or you can refer to a DVD if your book came at one.
So on this side over here, we have an anterior view of the heart.
So this over here is the right ventricle, this huge area here.
Coming over here, we have the left ventricle.
Now this part down over here, this is the apex of the heart.
And then as we come up over here, this is the ascending aorta.
Remember, the aorta is the largest artery we have in our body.
Then we have the branches that are coming off of this aorta.
We have the brachiocephalic trunk, the left common choroid artery, and the left subclavian
artery.
This is the pulmonary trunk, which is going to divide into right and left pulmonary arteries,
which will go to the lungs.
One goes to the right side, to the right lung, the other goes to the left side, to the left
lung.
Then over here, you can see the oracle for the right atrium, and here is the oracle for
the left atrium.
Then over here, this is the right coronary artery, which is lying in the coronary sulcus.
Now coming over here, this is the interventricular sulcus over here.
And this is the anterior interventricular artery.
And here you can see some of the additional branches of the left coronary artery over here.
And this side here, we have another animation of the heart, so be sure to refer to the Pearson
website, or the DVD that may have come with your book, or you can also just search for
it on YouTube.
Moving onto the valves of the heart, their purpose is to make sure blood flows in a single
direction throughout the heart.
The valves open and close in response to the differences in blood pressure on their two
sides.
The two major types of valves we have are the atrium ventricular valves, and thysemi-lunar
valves.
The atria ventricular valves are also known as the AV valves, and they are found between
the atria and ventricles, while the semilunar valves are found between the ventricles and
major arteries.
There aren't any valves present at the entrance of the superior and inferior vena cava, in
addition to the pulmonary veins at the right and left atrium.
While we do get a small amount of blood that flows back into these vessels during atrial
contraction, the backflow is minimal due to the heart's contraction, which compresses
the venous points of entry.
Additionally, the inertia of incoming blood also prevents backflow.
And this slide here, we look at pictures of the heart valves.
So over here, this is the right side of the heart, so on the right side of the heart we
find the tricuspid valve, and on the left side we find the bicuspid valve.
Another name for the bicuspid valve is the mitral valve.
Now both tricuspid and the bicuspid valves are atrial ventricular valves, because we
find them between the atria and ventricles.
The other valves we have are the semilunar valves, and those are the euretic semilunar
valve and the pulmonary semilunar valve.
The euretic semilunar valve, we find between the left ventricle and the euretic, while
the pulmonary semilunar valve, we find between the right ventricle and the pulmonary trunk.
Now going to this photograph over here, it's very easy to distinguish the different types
of valves.
So when you look over here, we have three cusps present, so easily you know this is the tricuspid
valve.
When you look over here, there's two cusps present, so you know this is the mitral or
bicuspid valve.
Now you have the semilunar valves.
How do you differentiate the semilunar valves?
Let me show you how.
When you find the tricuspid and bicuspid valve, and then you find this semilunar valve over
here, the one that's closest to these tricuspid and bicuspid valve is going to be the euretic
semilunar valve.
Then you just have one more semilunar valve that's left, which is the pulmonary semilunar
valve.
So as long as you can distinguish this, this euretic semilunar valve, then you should know
where this pulmonary semilunar valve is.
Now let's get a bit of more detail into the h-reventricular valves.
So the two h-reventricular valves or the AV valves, as they're also known, their main
purpose is to prevent the backflow of blood into the atria when the ventricles contract.
The tricuspid valve, which is also called the right AV valve, is made up of three cusps,
and we find that between the right atria and right ventricle.
The bicuspid or the mitral valve, or which is also called the left atria ventricular
valve, is made up of two cusps, and we find that between the left atria and left ventricle.
The corded tenonae are these rope-like structures that anchor the cusps of the AV valves to
the papillary muscles, and they function to hold the valve flaps in a closed position.
Additionally, they prevent the flaps from opening up back into the atria.
So in this slide over here, notice over here you can see these corded tenonae, and these
are these rope-like structures that are attaching on one end to the cusps of the AV valves,
and on the other end to the papillary muscles.
So over here when you look, here's another papillary muscle, and off these papillary
muscles you can see the corded tenonae, and then these corded tenonae attach these AV
valves.
And over here you can see it as well.
So here's a papillary muscle here, there's another papillary muscle here, here are the
corded tenonae, and here are the valves, the AV valves, and this is the mitral valve.
This slide goes over the functions of the atria ventricular valves.
Now pay close attention to this, if you understand this concept, it's gonna make other parts
of the lecture so much easier to understand.
So what they're trying to tell you is this, as the pressure in the upper chambers, regardless
if you're looking at the right atrium or the left atrium, as blood starts to come inside
to this chamber and the pressure increases, it's gonna force these atria ventricular valves
to open up.
When is that gonna happen?
When the pressure in the right atrium is greater than that of the right ventricle, or if you're
looking at this chamber over here, when the pressure is greater in the left atrium, then
it is in the left ventricle, right?
Let's just stick to the side for now.
So when the pressure is greater in the right atrium than it is in the right ventricle,
this valve's gonna open up.
Now usually that happens when this chamber is empty, okay?
So when this chamber is empty, the pressure over here is gonna be much greater.
What is that gonna do?
It's gonna push these valves open.
When these valves open up, the blood that's over here is gonna start filling up this chamber.
Now as this chamber starts to fill up, what's gonna happen then is that this atrium is gonna
contract.
When it contracts, whatever blood that's left over, is gonna get pushed on over here.
By that time, this entire chamber should be full.
When that happens, it's gonna close these valves back up, okay?
So the ends of these cups, they close, they meet one another.
Now what's gonna happen is this chamber over here, this right ventricle, is going to contract.
Now when this right ventricle contracts, blood is gonna want to go somewhere.
Where will blood go anywhere there is an opening?
So there's two options, blood can go over here or blood can go over here.
We want the blood to go over here.
This is a pulmonary trunk, which eventually is gonna end up leading the blood 2D right
in left lungs.
So how do we make sure blood goes over here and doesn't end up going back over this way?
Well here's the thing, if we didn't have these quartetinini attached these cusps over here,
what would happen is when this chamber contracts, the pressure would end up pushing these cups
back into this chamber over here.
Then we'd have blood going over here as well as over here.
In other words, blood would go over both ways.
In addition to that, the pressure would be low, it wouldn't be too high to have blood
going this direction.
We have a big mess going on, alright?
You can't live like that.
If that would happen, life would not be sustainable.
So these structures over here, these quartetinini, what they do is they attach to these cusps.
When this chamber contracts, remember the quartetinini, on one end, they're attached
to the cusps.
On the other end, they're attached to these papillary muscles.
So when this chamber, when this left ventricle contracts, when these muscles contract, these
papillary muscles also contract.
When they contract, they pull on these cusps of these AV valves, taut.
So what ends up happening is when the pressure is starting to push against these valves,
these guys are pulling it down a little bit.
And because they're pulling it down, they're keeping it taut, the blood is not going to
get a backbone because these valves are not going to end up getting pushed back.
They're being pulled downwards.
Same thing happens on this end as well.
So what option does blood have?
It has no other option, but to go over here in this direction into the pulmonary trunk.
And the same thing happens over here on this side.
When these left ventricle contracts, the papillary muscles also contract, and they pull down
on these quartetinini, which are connected to the mitral valves, and it keeps these stiff.
It doesn't prevent, the mitral valves won't open up back into the left atrium.
So blood has no other option, but to go into the aorta.
They pass the aortic semilunar valves and enter the aorta.
Looking at this illustration here, here we have the papillary muscle, here are the quartetinini,
and here are the atriventricular valves, the cusp of an atriventricular valve.
So the quartetinini are attached to the cusp of the atriventricular valve on one end, and
the papillary muscle on the other end.
Now remember, when this ventricle contracts, the papillary muscle will also contract, and
when they contract, they pull down on the quartetinini.
The quartetinini in return ends up keeping these cusps taught, because remember, when
this chamber is full of blood, and when it contracts, blood is going to want to go wherever
there is an opening.
There's an opening over here, it's going to want to go up this way, and if it ends
up pushing up these valves, these valves can eventually open up into this upper chamber.
But because we have these quartetinini, and they're pulling down because of these papillary
muscles, that blood can try to push its way up, but it won't.
Because the pressure over here, it's quite firm, it's taught.
It's not going to allow these cusps to open up, and blood will end up going to the only
way it can go, which in this case, for example, if we're looking at this chamber here, this
left ventricle, it's going to end up going to this aortic semi lunar valve.
So again, we're looking at this illustration, so what do we have here?
We are looking at this tricuspid valve here, the bicuspid valve here, and then we have
these semi lunar valves here.
This is the eurex semi lunar valve, and the pulmonary semi lunar valve.
Now let's move on to the semi lunar valves.
So as you know already, we have two semi lunar valves, and their job is to prevent the
back flow of blood from the major arteries back into the ventricles.
Like the AV valves, they also open and close in response to the pressure changes.
Each valve is made up of three cusps, and when you look at these valves, they kind of
look like half moons, which is how they get the name semi lunar.
Now the pulmonary semi lunar valve, we find that located between the right ventricle and
the pulmonary trunk, and the eurex semi lunar valve, we find located between the left ventricle
and the aorta.
Coming back to this point over here, in regards to the opening and closing of the semi lunar
valves, in response to the pressure changes, remember when you look at the atrial ventricular
valves, we said the AV valves would open when the chamber in the atria was greater
than that of the ventricle.
Now in the case of the semi lunar valves, the pressure has to be greater than the ventricle
than in the blood vessels.
So in the example of the pulmonary semi lunar valve, the pressure in the right ventricle
needs to be greater than that of the pulmonary trunk.
And in the case of the eurex semi lunar valve, the pressure in the left ventricle needs to
be greater than that of the pressure in the aorta.
This slide along with the next slide goes over the opening and closing of the semi lunar
valves.
So when you look over here, this is a right ventricle.
When this chamber is full of blood, and this chamber contracts, blood is going to want
to go somewhere.
We already learned why it can't go over in this direction.
And now where is it going to go?
It's going to go over here.
How can it go over here?
The only way that's going to happen is if the pressure in this chamber is greater than
the pressure in this blood vessel.
When this pressure is much greater than the pressure over here, blood is going to get
forced out this way.
It's going to push these valves open, as you can see over here, and we'll enter this
blood vessel over here.
This is a pulmonary trunk, all right, and you can see the cusps opening up and blood
is flowing through.
Now in this slide, what we're looking at is blood is now inside the blood vessels over
here, okay?
So what's happening over here in these chambers?
There's no blood left.
In other words, the pressure is much lower over here, and the pressure is much greater
over here.
So now what happens is once, when you look over here, let's go back to this picture.
Remember, when blood pressure was much greater in this chamber, blood pushed through.
When they pushed through, these valves opened up.
Now that the valve, the pressure is no longer greater, these valves end up falling back
onto themselves.
As you can see over here, the valves collapse back, and blood is now sitting on top over
here, okay?
Blood cannot come back down here anymore, all right?
So this is how these valves open and they close.
At this point in this image, what we're looking at is the pressure is greater inside this
blood vessel, which is a pulmonary trunk.
When it is inside this, right ventricle, or it could be the other case as well.
The pressure inside the aorta is greater than the pressure inside the left ventricle.
And when that's the case, these valves stay closed.
A couple of hard valve disorders worth mentioning are incompetent valves and valvular stenosis.
As we saw in several of the pictures on the previous slides, the valves are quite simple
structures, nothing too sophisticated, but sometimes these valves can become leaky.
But as long as it's not a large leak that causes too much of an impairment, they'll
continue to function and not compromise the function of the heart.
But if there are larger leaks at these valves, it's indicative of greater valve issues and
can cause cardiac compromise.
When you have it incompetent valve, the heart valve is not closing properly, so some of
the blood back flows back into the chamber and gets pumped over and over again.
When valvular stenosis, the heart valve becomes stiff and constricts the opening.
This usually happens because of scar tissue that forms from a condition such as endocarditis
or calcium salt deposits, so now the heart has to contract with more force to push the
blood out of the chamber.
In both of these conditions, the heart has to work much harder, and over time, this takes
a toll on the heart, resulting in its weakening.
So what needs to be done is to replace the defective valve, and usually this valve happens
even the mitral valve.
The defective valve gets replaced with either a mechanical valve, a cow or pig valve, or
a valve from a human cadaver.
Now it's worth mentioning that the pig and cow valves are chemically treated to prevent
rejection.
As to which valve is better, there's not really a clear-cut answer to that.
The mechanical valve will usually last between 28-25 years, but you have to be on blood thinners
the whole time.
Compared to the tissue valve transplants, you really don't need to be on blood thinners
for that.
It's up to the doctor to decide perhaps you have another condition that the doctor may
want you to be on a blood thinner for.
Also, scientists and researchers are currently trying to use the patient's own cells to
produce new tissue, new heart valve tissues.
So how successful that will be, only time will tell.
Now let's go over the pathway of blood through the heart.
We start off on the right side of the heart.
The superior vena cava, inferior vena cava, and the coronary sinus all bring blood back
to the right atrium of the heart.
When the pressure in the right atrium is grey enough, it's going to push these tricuspid
valves open and the blood will fall into the right ventricle.
When the right ventricle contracts, blood is going to be forced through the pulmonary
semilunar valves and enter the pulmonary trunk.
The pulmonary trunk then divides into the right and left pulmonary arteries, which go
to the lungs, and at the lungs, the carbon dioxide will be unloaded and the oxygen will
be loaded into the blood.
The freshly oxygenated blood will then travel by way of the four pulmonary veins.
The right and left pulmonary veins returns the blood back to the left atrium of the heart.
From the left atrium, blood is going to pass through the mitral valves and into the left
ventricle.
When the left ventricles contract, the blood will pass through the eoridic semilunar valves
and enter the aorta, and from the aorta, blood will enter systemic circulation.
This slide here along with the next illustrates a flow of blood through the heart.
Looking at the legend over here, the blood represents the oxygenated blood, while the
right represents oxygenated blood.
So again, the flow of blood starts on the right side of the heart.
So we have the superior vena cava, the inferior vena cava, and the coronary signs, which are
going to return blood back to the right chamber of the heart, the right atrium.
Now when the right atrium fills up with blood, the next thing that is going to happen is
that it's going to force this tricuspid valve to open up and enter the right ventricle.
Remember, this happens when the pressure is greater in the right atrium than it is in
the right ventricle.
Now once the right ventricle is full of blood, the next thing that's going to happen is
this right ventricle will contract.
When the right ventricle contracts and the pressure is greater in the right ventricle
than it is in the pulmonary trunk, these pulmonary semilunar valves will open up and
blood will then fill up this pulmonary trunk.
From the pulmonary trunk, the blood will then go to the right pulmonary artery and the left
pulmonary artery to the lungs.
In the lungs, the carbon dioxide will unload and oxygen will be loaded into the blood and
then it's going to end up returning back to the heart by way of the right and left pulmonary
veins.
So on this side here you can see the right and left pulmonary veins returning blood back
to the left atrium.
When the left atrium fills up with blood and the pressure is greater in the left atrium
than it is in the left ventricle, the bicuspid or mitral valves will force open and the blood
will fill the left ventricle.
When the left ventricle is full of blood and this chamber is contracting and the pressure
is greater in this chamber at that point than it is in the aorta, blood will then force
through the aortic semilunar valve and enter the aorta.
And from the aorta, blood will enter a systemic circulation where it's going to deliver the
oxygenated blood to the tissues of the body and it's going to end up picking up the carbon
dioxide.
And from there, the blood is going to make its return trip back to the heart.
And this slide over here is an overview of the previous two slides.
So once again, the superior vena cava, the inferior vena cava and the coronary sinus
bring blood back to this right atrium of the heart.
When the right atrium of the heart fills up with blood and the pressure is greater in
the right atrium than it is in the right ventricle, blood will pass through the tricuspid valve
and fill the right ventricle with blood.
Now when the right ventricle is full of blood and when the right ventricle is contracting,
the pressure is going to be greater in the right ventricle than it is going to be in
the pulmonary trunk.
When that happens, the pulmonary semilunar valves open up allowing the blood to enter
the pulmonary trunk and then move into the right and left pulmonary arteries.
The right and left pulmonary arteries will take the blood to the lungs where it's going
to unload the carbon dioxide and load on the oxygen.
And there, blood is going to return back to the left atrium of the heart by way of the
right and left pulmonary veins.
When blood is full in the left atrium and the pressure is greater in the left atrium
than it is in the left ventricle, what's going to happen next is that the blood is going
to pass through these mitral valves.
It's going to force this way open, cause these mitral valves to open up and fill up
into the left ventricle.
Now when the left ventricle contracts and the pressure in the left ventricle is greater
than the aorta, the blood is going to pass through the aorta semilunar valves and enter
the aorta.
From the aorta, blood is going to enter a systemic circulation where blood is going to
supply the tissues of the body with oxygen and remove the carbon dioxide.
And from that point on, the blood will return its journey back to the heart.
Once again, I want to point out to you to keep in mind that the right side of the heart
is a pulmonary circuit pump while the left side of the heart is a systemic circuit pump.
And keep in mind what I told you about arteries in veins earlier on.
Always think of arteries as pumping blood away from the heart and veins bringing blood
back to the heart.
When you look at the heart, never think about veins carrying deoxygenated blood and arteries
carrying oxygenated blood.
Remember, the right and left pulmonary arteries carry deoxygenated blood while the right and
left pulmonary veins carry oxygenated blood.
This is the only exception in the body where you'll find veins carrying oxygenated blood
while the arteries carry deoxygenated blood.
With that said, while at any given moment we have equal volumes of blood that are being
pumped to the pulmonary and systemic circuits, the workloads of the ventricles are uneven.
The right ventricle which serves the pulmonary circuit is a short low pressure circuit.
Remember, when the right ventricle contracts, blood doesn't need to go too far.
The blood is being pumped to the lungs which is in close proximity to the heart.
When you go to the left side of the heart, the left ventricle serves the systemic circuit
which is a long pathway through the entire body.
The blood is being pumped against gravity to the face and brain, is being pumped to the
extremities reaching our fingers and toes.
So this circuit is in covering much more resistance to blood flow, about 5 times as much friction.
And these functional differences are evident in the anatomy of the ventricles.
As we saw in the previous slides and had mentioned, the walls of the left ventricle are 3 times
thicker than that of the right ventricle.
So the left ventricle is able to generate much more pressure than the right ventricle
which makes it a much more powerful pump.
So on this slide over here, notice how much thicker the walls of the left ventricle are
compared to that of the right ventricle.
Additionally, look at the shape of the right ventricle.
This has more of a crescent shape while the left ventricle has more of a circular shape
and it's both of these differences that allow the left ventricle to be a much more powerful
pump than that of the right ventricle.
While the heart is constantly filled with blood in the chambers, it provides very little
nourishment to the heart tissue itself.
So how does the heart receive its oxygen and nutrients?
The answer to that question is through the coronary circulation.
Coronary circulation is a functional blood supply of the heart, in addition to being
the shortest circulation of the body.
As after the blood circulates around the heart, it gets delivered back into the right
atrium when the heart is relaxed.
And without surprise, the left ventricle receives most of the coronary blood supply.
The right and left coronary arteries both arise from the base of the aorta and then circle
the heart in the coronary sulcus.
These are the blood vessels that provide the arterial supply of the coronary circulation.
The branching of the coronary arteries also varies among individuals.
For example, in 15% of the population, the left coronary artery gives rise to both intraventricular
arteries, and in about 4% of the people, a single coronary artery supplies the entire
heart.
We also find many anisemoses or junctions among the coronary arterial branches, and while these
function to provide additional rods for blood delivery to the heart muscle, they aren't
enough to supply enough oxygen and nutrients when the coronary artery is blocked.
And unfortunately, when you have a complete block of a coronary artery, it leads to tissue
death and a heart attack.
It's also worth mentioning that while the heart only accounts for about 1-200 of the total
body weight, it requires 1-20 of the body's blood supply.
The left coronary artery runs towards the left side of the heart and then divides into
two major branches, which are the anterior interventricular artery and the circumflex
artery.
Additionally, the left coronary artery supplies the intraventricular septum, the anterior ventricular
walls, the left atrium, and the posterior wall of the left ventricle.
The anterior interventricular artery, which is also known as the left anterior de-centering
artery, follows the anterior interventricular septum, and supplies blood to the interventricular
septum and anterior walls of both ventricles.
The circumflex artery supplies the left atrium and the posterior walls of the left ventricle.
The right coronary artery crosses to the right side of the heart, where it also gives rise
to two major branches, which are the right marginal artery and the posterior interventricular
artery.
Additionally, the right coronary artery supplies the right atrium and most of the right ventricle.
The right marginal artery serves the myocardium of the lateral right side of the heart, while
the posterior interventricular artery runs to the heart's apex and supplies the posterior
ventricular walls.
And close to the heart's apex, the artery merges with the anterior interventricular
artery.
So in this slide over here, we have the picture of the heart, and we can see the arteries over
here.
Since this is the right side of the heart, here we have the right coronary artery, and
over here we have the left coronary artery.
So following the right coronary artery, you'll notice we have the right marginal artery that
comes off over here, and also we have the posterior interventricular artery that comes
off of it.
And then on the left side, for the left coronary artery, we have the circumflex arteries that
come off of it, and then as we continue downwards, we have the anterior interventricular artery,
and the anterior interventricular artery, and the posterior interventricular artery.
They end up connecting with one another.
So over here, this is an anisomosis, you can see here, the other structures, let's see.
So here, this is the left ventricle, and this area over here is the right ventricle.
Here's the right atrium, this is the oracle of the right atrium, and here's the oracle
of the left atrium.
This is the pulmonary trunk we have here.
This is the aorta, and this is the superior vena cava that you see over here.
So after the oxygen-rich arterial blood passes through the capillaries of the myocardium,
the venous blood gets picked up by the cardiac veins.
The coronary veins follow a path very similar to those of the coronary arteries.
The coronary veins come together to form this large blood vessel called the coronary sinus.
And if you remember from a handful of slides ago, the coronary sinus is the blood vessel
which empties into the right atrium.
The three large veins that connect to form the coronary sinus are the great cardiac vein,
which is found in the anterior interventricular sulcus, the middle cardiac vein that's found
in the posterior interventricular sulcus, and the small cardiac vein, which is found running
along the right inferior margin of the heart.
We also find several anterior cardiac veins which empty directly into the anterior aspect
of the right atrium.
In this side here, you can see the great cardiac vein, the middle cardiac vein, and the small
cardiac vein merging to form this coronary sinus, which will...
cardiac vein, which ends up...
In this side here, we can see the great cardiac vein which is coming off the anterior interventricular
sulcus, the middle cardiac vein which is coming off the posterior interventricular sulcus,
and the small cardiac vein which is coming off the inferior margin to form this coronary
sinus, and the coronary sinus will empty into the right atrium.
Also we see these anterior cardiac veins which directly empty into the right atrium.
Here we have a very good view of the posterior aspect of the heart.
So here's the inferior vena cava here, we have the superior vena cava over here, which
are both connected to this right atrium.
You can see the aorta over here, here's our left pulmonary artery, and the right pulmonary
artery here, here we have the left pulmonary veins, and the right pulmonary veins here.
And here we can see the oracle of the left atrium, and here's the right atrium over here,
and here is the apex of the heart.
So coming off the apex, going up we can see right over here, this is going to be our middle
cardiac vein, and over here we can see our great cardiac vein.
Here's the coronary sinus over here, this is the posterior vein of the left ventricle
over here, and what else could we see that's worth mentioning.
Here's our right coronary artery over here, this will be our left coronary artery over
here, and that's about it for this slide.
And Jana Pektorus literally translates to choke chest, this is when someone experiences
chest pain, which is caused by a brief deficiency in blood delivery to the heart.
This could happen from stress induced spasms of the coronary arteries, or from the heart
working too hard.
In angina, the heart cells don't die, remember it's only a brief deficiency in blood delivery,
so the heart cells get weak, but they don't die.
Now on the other hand, when you have a prolonged coronary blockage, it could lead to a heart
attack.
The medical term for a heart attack is MI, or myocardial infarction.
So when you have a MI, what's happening is that the heart cells are dying, and if you
think back to chapter four on tissues, you'll remember that heart cells do not reproduce
their amitotic cells, so what ends up happening when cells die is that they get replaced with
scar tissue, and scar tissue does not contract.
Addressing the question of whether a person will survive NMI depends on several factors
which you won't get into, but very simplistically, just looking at the heart itself, it depends
on how much damage there is to the heart tissue, and where the damage occurred.
So if you're looking at a large area of the love ventricle that's been damaged, you're
looking at a very serious condition, this is the main pump that will be pumping blood
to the entire system, so if you can't generate enough force, then the person probably will
not survive.
Moving on to the microscopic anatomy of the heart, just like skeletal muscles, cardiac
muscles are also striated and contract by the sliding filament mechanism.
However, unlike skeletal muscle fibers which are multinucleated, long and cylindrical,
cardiac muscle cells are fat, branched, short and interconnected cells with either a single
or dual-centrally located nuclei.
The mitochondria are considered as much as 25-35% of the heart cells volume, and this
is what makes heart cells highly resistant to fatigue, the remaining volume is taken
up by myofibrils made up of typical sarcomeres that have Z-discs, A-bans and I-bans present.
And compared to skeletal muscles, the T-tubules of cardiac muscles are wider and less numerous,
only entering the cell once at the Z-discs, whereas in skeletal muscles, we saw them twice
per sarcomere.
Additionally, the sarcoplasmic reticulum is simpler than that of skeletal muscle.
They also lack the large terminal cisternals we see in skeletal muscles, which is why there
aren't any triads present.
Intercaliated discs are the junctions where the plasma membrane of adjacent cardiac cells
interlock with one another, and it's at the intercaliated discs where desmosomes and gap
junctions occur.
The desmosomes hold the cardiac cells together so they don't separate during contraction.
The gap junctions allow the ions to pass from cell to cell, which is what transmits current
across the entire heart.
And because the gap junctions electrically couples the myocardial cells, the myocardium
behaves as a single coordinated unit, which is described by the term "functional synchium".
The intracellular spaces between the cells are filled with the loose connective tissue
matrix called the endomycium, which contains numerous capillaries.
And this is connected to the fibrous skeleton that acts like a tendon and insertion given
the myocardial cells something to pull or exert their force against.
And this slide over here, this right over here is a microscopic picture of cardiac muscle
tissue.
So these are the heart cells over here.
And for example, if you look at this heart cell over here, this one has two nuclei that
are present.
Right over here, you can see these intracellular discs that are present as well.
And coming over here, these are the gap junctions.
This is what electrically connects the muscle cells.
So the ions will transfer from cell to cell by these gap junctions.
And the desmosomes over here, this was holding the cells together, this is what's keeping
them from pulling apart when the heart contracts.
On this side over here, we're looking at a microscopic illustration of cardiac muscle.
Now coming down over here, here's a heart muscle cell, here's this nucleus, and this
is an intra-caliated disc.
Now when you look over here, notice a numerous mitochondria that are present.
Additionally, you can see another nucleus over here, and over here we have the gap junctions
and the desmosomes.
Notice both of these are found at the intra-calated disc.
Now moving down over here, here's another nucleus, and here's the sarcolemma.
Now when you look over here, we have the Z disc, the I band, and the A band that are present.
Also you can see the thick and the thin filaments.
Now coming over here, notice we have a much simpler sarco plus a reticulum present than
we saw in the skeletal muscle.
And also when you look at the T-tubules, they have only one T-tubule per sarcomere,
whereas in skeletal muscle, we saw two T-tubules per sarcomere.
And again, this circle plus a reticulum is much simpler, we don't have triads present
over here either.
Now let's look at some physiological similarities between skeletal and cardiac muscle.
In both skeletal and cardiac muscle, contraction is preceded by depolarization in the form
of an action potential.
The transmission of the depolarization wave down the T-tubule is that causes the circle
plus a reticulum to release calcium into the sarcoplasm.
And the excitation and contraction coupling occurs as calcium provides a signal for the
cross-bridge activation.
Now let's see how these two muscle cells differ from one another.
We actually find two types of heart muscle cells.
We have contractile cells and pacemaker cells.
The bulk of the cells in the heart are the contractile cells, which are responsible for
the heart's pumping abilities.
At pacemaker cells, we find in specific locations which have the ability to spontaneously depolarize.
This unique property is referred to as automaticity or autoarithmicity.
And since we have gap junctions in the heart which pass the action potential from cell
to cell, these cells not only depolarize themselves, but they depolarize their entire
heart, which is why neural input isn't needed.
In the heart transplants, when all the nerves of the heart are cut, the heart is still able
to beat.
Compared to skeletal muscles, each muscle fiber has to be stimulated by a nerve ending
to contract.
And if a nerve is cut, it'll cause paralysis of the muscle.
As I mentioned earlier, the heart contracts as a single unit.
Remember, the gap junctions allow the ions to pass from one cell to another to form a
functional synchium.
And this is what allows the wave of depolarization to travel from cell to cell across the heart.
So in return, either all fibers in the heart contract as a unit or the heart won't contract
at all.
And it's the contraction of all the heart's muscle cells that ensures the effective pumping
of the heart.
Skeletal muscles on the other hand are individually stimulated by nerve fibers to contract.
Next, it's the influx of calcium ions from the extracellular fluid that triggers calcium
release from the circle plasm reticulum in heart cells.
Skeletal muscles, on the other hand, don't use extracellular calcium.
In skeletal muscle, depolarization directly causes the release of all the calcium that's
needed for contraction from the circle plasm reticulum.
In cardiac muscle, depolarization opens slow calcium channels in the circle lemma, which
allows 10-20% of the calcium that's needed for contraction to enter.
This influx of calcium causes calcium sensitive channels in the circle plasm reticulum to
release bursts of calcium that are caused by the remaining 80-90% of the calcium needed
for contraction.
Technic contraction cannot occur in heart muscle.
Remember, the absolute refractory period is the period during an action potential when
another action potential can't be triggered.
In skeletal muscle, the absolute refractory period is shorter than the contraction, which
is what allows multiple contractions to summit, which is what technique contraction is.
But the hard work to contract this way, it wouldn't be able to relax and fill, it would
be useless.
Cardiac muscle fibers have longer absolute refractory periods than muscle fibers.
In heart muscles, the absolute refractory is almost as long as the contraction itself.
This is what prevents technic contraction.
And this is what allows the heart to relax and fill the chambers and pump the blood efficiently.
A handful of slides ago, I mentioned that heart muscle cells have more mitochondria than
skeletal muscles do.
If it didn't occur to you then, I'm telling you now that heart cells require a lot more
oxygen for energy metabolism than skeletal muscles do.
The heart relies almost exclusively on aerobic respiration, so it can't function effectively
for long without oxygen.
And if you remember back to skeletal muscles, they're able to work for prolonged periods
by carrying out anaerobic respiration.
Both skeletal and cardiac muscles are able to use multiple fuel sources, such as fatty
acids and glucose.
However, myocytes are much more adaptable and readily switch to metabolic pathways to
utilize whatever nutrients are available, including lactic acid.
But it must have oxygen present.
This slide here goes over a table 18.1, which is an excellent study table that goes over
the key differences between skeletal and cardiac muscle.
So let's start off over here on structure.
When you look at skeletal muscle, we find cells that are striated through long, cylindrical
in shape and multinucleated.
When you look at cardiac muscles on the other hand, these cells are striated also, but these
are short, they're highly branched, and there's only one or two nuclei per cell.
As far as the presence of gap junctions between the cell, we don't find them in skeletal
muscle, but we do find them in cardiac muscle.
As far as the cells contracting as a unit, skeletal muscles do not contract as a unit.
The mourines must be stimulated individually.
In cardiac muscles, they do contract as a unit.
Because of the gap junctions that are present, it creates a functional synchium.
As far as two tubules, they're present in both skeletal and cardiac muscle.
However, they're far more abundant in skeletal muscle than they are in cardiac muscle, but
they are much wider in cardiac muscle.
For the circle plasm reticulum, in the skeletal muscles, they're much more elaborate than
they are in cardiac muscle, and we also find terminal cisterns in the skeletal muscle.
In cardiac muscle, there is no terminal cistern present.
As for the source of calcium for contraction, in skeletal muscle, it comes from the circle
plasm reticulum only.
In cardiac muscle, it comes from the circle plasm reticulum and extracellular fluid.
And calcium binds to troponin in both skeletal and cardiac muscle.
As far as the presence of pace microcells, they're not present in skeletal muscle.
They're only found in cardiac muscle.
As far as tetanus being possible, it's possible in skeletal muscle, but it's not possible
in cardiac muscle.
As far as the supply of ATP goes, in skeletal muscle, ATP is produced both aerobically and
anaerobically.
Remember, there's fewer mitochondria present in skeletal muscle.
In cardiac muscle, on the other hand, we have a lot more mitochondria present, and ATP is
only able to be produced by the aerobic pathway.
And that's it for the first part of chapter 18.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you liked this video, please be sure to give it a thumbs up.
Also, please be sure to share with your friends, your classmates, your instructor, anybody
you think that may find it helpful.
Once again, thank you so much for watching, and best of luck.